und darüber wollen wir mit dem fdp chef
selbst reden guten abend herr lindner
guten abend russland sie stellen morgen
die vertrauensfrage wie groß ist ihre
befürchtungen dass ihnen wichtige
parteifreunde die gefolgschaft
verweigern
ich hoffe auf eine starke rückendeckung
mir selbst ist es jedenfalls möglich
meinen abend weiter fortzusetzen
das wäre nicht möglich gewesen wenn es
nicht eine ganz klare abgrenzung von der
afg gegeben hätte der kurs der fdp darf
nicht in frage gestellt werden
in thüringen ist es passiert dass eine
gut gemeinte kandidatur als signal es
gibt alternativen zu afd und linkspartei
sich in eine katastrophe verwandelt hat
nämlich in die katastrophe dass die afd
ihren kandidaten hat stehen lassen und
überraschen cover wählte die wahl lassen
kann nicht fortgesetzt
überraschend war das denn in meinem
waren sie ja sogar schon von der cdu
chefin vor genau diesem szenario gewarnt
worden
das war offensichtlich eine information
die frau kramp karrenbauer aus ihrer
unionsfraktion hatte das ist dort
bestrebungen gegeben hat die abgrenzung
zur fdp als koalitionspartner im
thüringer landtag seitens der
unionsfraktion ist ja auch viel weiter
als unsere wir schließen uns nämlich
prinzipiell aus thomas kemmerich hat
immer unterstrichen es ist ein
politisches signal
es gibt eine mitte im parlament und es
ist richtig und gut dass er jetzt binnen
eines tages klarheit geschaffen naja
diese klarheit hätte man ja schon
gestern schaffen können sie hatten ja
die möglichkeit sich vor der presse
genauso klar wie der social herr söder
gemacht hat zu äußern und zu sagen geht
gar nicht und nicht erst 24 stunden zu
warten dass ganz viele schnell
rauskommen und plötzlich sagen das
wollen wir nicht
ich habe am gestrigen tag hier bereits
angedeutet dass ich für den fall dass es
keine klaren verhältnisse in thüringen
keine klare abgrenzung gibt mein amt als
parteivorsitzender nicht fortsetzen
würde außerdem habe ich bereits gestern
von der notwendigkeit von neuwahlen
gesprochen wenn es nicht im
demokratischen zentrum eine
überparteiliche lösung eine
überparteiliche zusammenarbeit gibt aber
völlig klar ist frau slomka und das will
ich auch gar nicht gar nicht
relativieren
ich wollte in einer solchen schwierigen
situation für
unsere fraktion dort das persönliche
gespräch suchen um mit den kolleginnen
und kollegen dort die lage zu
analysieren und dann zu entscheidungen
zu kommen sagt er hätte permanent vorher
mit ihnen telefoniert er laufend mit
ihnen in kontakt gewesen und sie hätten
jede menge gespräche geführt
wir brauchen jetzt gerade sprachen sie
vom gestrigen abend jetzt sprechen auch
von den tagen davor bevor es überhaupt
zu diesem ganzen balkan
ja aber das war nicht nur ich damit herr
kemmerich im gespräch war sondern die
deutsche öffentlichkeit weil das
öffentliche beschlüsse waren dass herr
kemmerich antreten würde um ein signal
gegen afd und linkspartei als die
einzigen optionen zu senden als eine
karikatur der mitte
ich habe bereits in der vergangenen
woche bei jeder gelegenheit deutlich
gemacht eine solche kandidatur kann
nicht auf die afg auf der afg aufbauen
es kann keine wie auch immer geartete
zusammenarbeit mit der ard geben hat
aber jetzt normal und er hat es genossen
haben sie ihnen denn vorher gesagt
lieber thomas das kannst du nicht machen
und wegen fünf thüringer abgeordneten
werde ich hier nicht auch meine eigenen
parteichef position geschossen
wir müssen nur mal kurz klarstellen die
situation war dass die afg einen eigenen
kandidaten aufgestellt hat
herr kemmerich selbst steht im
schärfsten kontrast zur afd ein mann der
liberalität der im wahlkampf vor der afg
gewarnt hat und jetzt ist dort zu fragen
wie es aber nicht die afg glaubwürdig
die haben einen kandidaten aufgestellt
und dann handstreichartig in einer
geheimen wahl plötzlich den fdp
kandidaten gewählt der überhaupt nichts
mit der afg zu tun hat und diese
situation war unerträglich und es ist
ein zeichen der notwendigen politischen
verantwortung dass schnellstmöglich zu
bereinigen noch einmal davor wurde ja
gewarnt haben sie ihn davor gewarnt und
warum haben sie nicht geraten wenn das
passieren sollte dann soll wenigstens so
schlau und sage ich nehme die wahl nicht
an
ja auch in gremien haben wir davor
gewarnt ich selbst man darf sich nicht
in eine abhängigkeit der afd begeben
die einschätzung war die afg hat einen
eigenen kandidaten die werden wohl ihren
eigenen kandidaten wären jetzt können
wir beide sie und ich im nachhinein
analysiert man hätte die wahl gar nicht
annehmen dürfen das ist immer so bei den
bei den beobachtern danach stunden
später ist man viel schlauer und weiß
was man tun muss
herr kemmerich war offensichtlich über
man noch spontan eine entscheidung
getroffen die wahl anzunehmen und jetzt
einen tag später hatte diese
entscheidung selbst korrigiert und ich
bin dann muss man menschliche maßstäbe
anlegen und auch erlauben dass jemand
sich selbst korrigieren aber man es um
das amt eines ministerpräsidenten geht
dann ist das doch kein spiel bei dem man
mal eben so übermannt wird und die
erkenntnis dass man so eine wahl nicht
annimmt die hatten viele in ihrer partei
zum beispiel alexander graf lambsdorff
schon gerne rannten danach aber die
situation war nun eine andere
die afg hatte einen eigenen kandidaten
und ich meine die fdp steht im
schärfsten kontrast zur afd kann jeder
beobachten im wahlkampf haben wir vor
der afg gewarnt und diese abgrenzung ist
für die fdp von enormer politischer
bedeutung denn es ist ja bekannt dass
wir in der steuer in der migrations der
klimapolitik eine andere position haben
als cdu spd und grüne vertrauensfrage
und einer richtigen politischen punkt
mussten wir morgen grenzen.de mache ich
zu ende
die abgrenzung von der afg ist für uns
konstitutiv das musste geklärt werden
die haben spielerisch ohne
glaubwürdigkeit einfach ihren kandidaten
hängen lassen und unseren gewählt der
nix mit denen zu tun hat und das musste
korrigiert wird aber genau dass er das
gerade das problem ob in dieser
abgrenzung noch geglaubt wird nachdem
sie sich dann von ein paar afd thüringer
abgeordneten so haben vorführen lassen
auch als parteichef deshalb haben wir
uns um die vertrauensfrage ich habe nein
mir geht es darum dass wir nach so einer
situation klar stellen ist die führung
legitimiert versammeln wir uns in einer
politischen situation muss man aus
meiner sicht zu machen bei
schwerwiegenden politischen ereignissen
geht es auch um die gemeinsame bewertung
eines solchen sachverhalt und bezogen
auf thüringen will ich noch mal sagen es
gab und es wird niemals geben eine
systematische zusammenarbeit oder auch
nur eine unfall weise zustande gekommene
zusammenarbeit mit der afd
das hat der heutige tag klar gemacht mit
einem harten schnitt und das erwarte ich
jetzt von anderen auch die cdu in
thüringen ist
zur stunde noch nicht bereit zu einer
neuwahl und sie hat noch nicht einmal
eine prinzipielle abgrenzung zur afg
beschlossen sondern nur eine abgrenzung
die zeitlich und inhaltlich kandidat ist
oder jetzt dazu sagen noch zum ende des
gesprächs dass wir das gespräch
aufzeichnen da haben jetzt 10 49 also 20
50 könnte sein dass bis zum beginn der
sendung sich dabei der cdu in thüringen
noch was getan hat
danke für das gespräch ich danke ihnen
fürs linke